ce samedi 30 décembre la veille du
réveillon une attaque sans précédent a
fait 25 morts dont C enfants à Belgorod
en Russie cela a fait suite à une
attaque de missile contre l'Ukraine
vendredi qualifié de massif par Kiev et
qui a fait une quarantaine de morts de
son côté la Russie a dénoncé le
bombardement sur Belgorod situé à une
trentaine de kilomè de la frontière
ukrainienne d'actes terroriste et a
accusé les forces ukrainiennes d'avoir
frappé en plein centre de la ville là où
les gens se promènent avant le Réveillon
du NouvelAn le lendemain en plein
réveillon du 31 décembre quatre
personnes ont été tuées et 13 blessées
par une frappe à n sous contrôle russe
en Ukraine la Russie affirme que Kief en
est responsable mais l'Ukraine est
restée muette en réponse ce lundi 1er
janvier Vladimir Poutine a promis
d'intensifier les frappes russes en
représaille de son côté vlodimir
Zelenski avait dans son discours pour la
nouvelle année promis de ravager les
forces russes résultat dans la nuit de
mardi au moins quatre personnes ont été
tuées et une quarantaine de personnes
blessées à keV et carkif en Ukraine dans
un nouveau bombardement massif par la
Russie selon les autorités ukrainiennes
une vingtaine de localités de la région
ont été touché par des attaques
d'artillerie et de mortiers ennemis ces
explosions ont retenti à kiief au moment
où l'Ukraine tentait de repousser une
attaque de drone sur sa capitale selon
l'armée ukrainienne 99 missiles russes
auraient été tirés dont 72 abattu ce
mardi matin l'armée de l'air ukrainienne
a annoncé sur telégram que des missiles
volaient en direction de la capitale
Kief restez dans les abris beaucoup de
missiles se dirige vers vous si l'année
2023 s'est pourtant soldée par l'échec
de la contre-offensive estivale de
l'Ukraine et le gel quasi total de la
ligne de front volodimir Zelenski a
affirmé que l'Ukraine disposera d'au
moins 1 million de drones
supplémentaires dans son arsenal l'année
prochaine ainsi que d'avion de chasse
F16 fourni par ses partenaires
occidentaux